all right but we begin with the latest
on those criminal charges against Alec
Baldwin stemming from the deadly
shooting on the film set of rust Baldwin
and the film's Firearms specialist
Hannah Gutierrez Reid will each face two
counts of involuntary manslaughter in
the 2021 death of cinematographer Helena
Hutchins prosecutors said the incident
in which Baldwin was holding a gun that
discharged revealed criminal disregard
for safety Alina Hutchins was 42 years
old she left behind a husband and a
young son Chris Van Cleef joins us now
from Santa Fe Chris good morning
well good morning Baldwin's lawyers say
they plan to vigorously fight these
felony charges calling it a terrible
miscarriage of justice but the D.A and
the special prosecutor brought in for
these cases say the evidence points to a
crime
are you doing okay no I'm not actually
this morning Alec Baldwin is facing up
to five years behind bars for
involuntary manslaughter charges
stemming from the shooting that ended
cinematographer Helena Hutchins life
Santa Fe District Attorney Mary Carmack
altwese was what happened on the rust
set preventable absolutely it was so
preventable if anybody had just done
their jobs were you were in the room
when the lady when someone was holding
the gun Baldwin was rehearsing a scene
for the movie rust when the gun
discharged in October 2021 killing
Hutchins and injuring director Joel
Souza here's Baldwin talking to
investigators after the shooting it
should have been a cold gun with no
rounds inside then later in an exclusive
interview with ABC news anchor George
Stephanopoulos I would never point a gun
when a pull and Trigger at them never
but prosecutors say the forensics from
an FBI report told a different story
this was recklessness this was a
negligent discharge of a firearm because
he pulled that trigger Hannah Gutierrez
Reid who was in charge of weapons on the
set is also facing two counts of
involuntary manslaughter assistant
director Dave Halls who inspected the
gun before giving it to Baldwin has
agreed to plead guilty to negligent use
of a deadly weapon it's still unclear
why live ammo was on the set to begin
with but in a statement Gutierrez Reid's
lawyer said the charges are the result
of a very flawed investigation and
predicted she'd be exonerated of
wrongdoing Hall's lawyer called his plea
deal appropriate Dave Halls carries a
lot of trauma and a lot of survivors
guilt over this special prosecutor
Andrea Reed will help the D.A prosecute
the cases I think that had any of those
three actually done their job that
Helena Hutchins would be alive today an
attorney for the Hutchins family called
the charges warranted and promised to
fully cooperate with this prosecution as
part of an earlier civil settlement
hutchin's husband became an executive
producer on Rust which was set to resume
filming this month it doesn't matter if
you're an A-list actor it doesn't matter
if it's your neighbor the law applies to
everybody and it applies to Mr Baldwin
and it's important that Helena Hutchins
gets Justice in this case
prosecutors plan to formally file those
charges in the coming days you will not
see Alec Baldwin arrested or in
handcuffs or any kind of a perp Walk The
Next Step will be court summons for a
first appearance that will likely be
done virtually Tony
all right Chris thank you very much